so first I have a technical question for
you because I am fascinated by the
motion control camera use in this movie
and also upgrade as well so what was
that like for you have you ever done
anything like that before
no I haven't and I'm a big
cinematography nerd and I was so excited
I was had I had an actual crush on this
camera on this equipment and I would
just I would just watch it and and I
just I loved it so much and the fact
that it went by the numbers and that it
did exactly what it wanted to do and you
had to follow it I was like this is the
coolest thing ever and the way that it
moves so fast truly is is just and then
obviously the result is incredible
there's things that you can do with it
that I just would be impossible for
humans the end result and the precision
of it just like boggles my brain I can't
handle it I can't handle it we would do
shots and with that camera the best part
is is you can't blame it you can't blame
the camera never blame the camera the
camera does what it's supposed to do
it's only you so we did this one thing
where I had to run in front of it and
it's like a car that's like a swipe car
you know where you make it all live like
one shot and we did it over and over and
over again because the timing of the
camera going from here to here and as I
run if I run across it if I missed it
the cameras going uh-huh
so my my run had to be so specific it
was one of the hardest things I've ever
done
what update what did you find the most
challenging thing about this shoot
because it's not even just that there's
all the fight sequences that it's like
such highly emotional moments that I
mean I don't act for this reason but it
looks like it probably weighs on you
quite a bit so of all of that shooting
in the rain what was the most
challenging emotional stuff as much
easier for me but the physical stuff is
harder the rain was fines it was not
cold I've been in colder rain before but
the physical stuff like the the fight
stuff
the you know just even like the running
and going over the wall like stuff like
that that I'm not used to doing that was
that was trickier also just the amount
of tension that you have to hold in your
body when you're playing ski
for mm-hmm an hour and a half or there's
never a plan where you also carried that
dog over the wall was there sous-sous I
couldn't stop thinking about what zoos
did for a month no he ended up being
hind November you know he's fine yeah I
feel like as long as the dog is fine I
am fine I mean I think I won in the end
basically so I wonder what do you think
it is about the horror genre that makes
it such a good format to dig into kind
of socio-political issues because I'm
just seeing more and more movies like
this and especially coming off of us as
well what do you think it is about the
genre that makes it such a useful tool
storytelling in that respect I think
that you know when you can go to the
theater and you can have a fun
experience and entertaining experience
enjoy yourself but then have something
to think or talk about afterwards those
are the kinds of movies I think I like
to see that a lot of people like to see
excuse me and horror sci-fi those kinds
of things because of the fantastical
element of it you're really able to put
that in there in an almost quote-unquote
invisible way and and really not have it
be a morality lesson not have it be
something you don't feel like you're
being lectured at you're able to see it
in a new light seeing it through this
sort of lens of whatever it is if it's
the Invisible Man or something like get
out I feel like we're in a very good
time with the genre agree that kind of
stuff yeah because it's on my mind from
this morning I have to ask you about
working with Wes Anderson I'm French
dispatch because that trailer it's
something else so what was it about
working with him that you've kind of
never experienced before just being in
that world of his I'm such a huge fan
and I have been for so long and to be in
that world I know dressed like I was in
a Wes Anderson movie with Bill Murray
and he everyone looks like they're in a
Wes Anderson film including him
including Wes Anderson it's like it just
was the most surreal sort of dream
experience do you ever take a break
no your your resume for the past three
years